excited hello there stop saying hello
there hello there Jerry since Joey said
that I'm like [ __ ] I love that sound I
don't perpetuated one thing I've always
wanted is like what why were prequel
memes just why how did they just become
a thing because you know with with
SpongeBob because they're just good
movies yeah are they though because
that's everyone [ __ ] haters are very
good yeah and they've they've been
something that have just like stayed
throughout you know I think that
prequels are better than the modern
Star Wars I haven't seen any of the
modern ones I've only seen one and I
didn't like it well did you did you
watch did you watch the prequels like
when they came out I don't know if you
are yeah okay yeah how old do you think
I don't [ __ ] know man well okay no I
was very young so yeah yeah yeah when
did episode one come out
yeah and my cousin dragged me don't drag
me I wanted to go he went to the theater
to watch Return of the Sith is that the
name return Revenge of the Sith yeah I
think you just mixed up about like three
movies
which is the third one six right
no six that's Return of the Jedi that's
Return of the Jedi it go okay wait okay
I'm gonna I'm about to test my Star Wars
I don't care
episode one Phantom Menace episode two
Clone Wars episode three when I was
saying six I meant I'm not old enough
for six I meant three and three right
episode three which is Revenge of the
Sith revenge of the series that's the
one I was talking about yeah the one
with the modern one you didn't want 2000
the first one not the modern modern one
the the prequel modern one okay so
episode one came out 1999. I remember
watching that when I was like four or
five one like DVD or VHS yes back then
yeah and then I went to the theater to
watch revenge of the city yeah yeah yes
episode three just episode three yeah
three and I remember that I didn't
really know what the [ __ ] was happening
yeah because he missed Clone Wars right
yeah I think I've watched Clone Wars I
don't know when but I remember just I
was I I was too young to follow the
right storyline of Star Wars I just like
the the shootie and the lightsaber read
which is honestly I mean that's yeah
yeah and then I rewatched it when I was
a little older and I didn't care yeah
like I remember the first Star Wars I
actually watched in theaters was the
Clone Wars I remember watching as a
teenager and just seeing like so many
Jedis seeing [ __ ] Samuel Jackson's
Mace Windu [ __ ] Yoda tearing [ __ ] up
I'm like this is amazing and then I
talked to my older cousin about it and
it's like the [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm like okay I
guess this [ __ ] I'm too good oh yeah
exact same way episode one
racing Darth Vader the fight with him in
uh what's his name
sorry Darth Maul sorry like the Darth
Maul fight with uh [ __ ] uh yeah yeah
that's the guy who's done that I don't
know you don't know why do I [ __ ]
know that yeah Liam Neeson I think that
like so you are Darth Maul like [ __ ]
villain oh yeah that [ __ ] scene where
he gets the [ __ ] double lightsaber
out as a kid that was the coolest [ __ ]
ever I remember for me it was just the
music okay I remember this one this one
cup that my me and my cousin like
recreated because we thought it was the
OG Star Wars kid I was I was okay
because because we saw the uh we saw the
Darth Maul versus Obi-Wan and Mace Windu
fight right sure it was badass yeah that
[ __ ] was bad oh sorry no no no no uh no
he he thought both of them right yeah he
did yeah did he yeah quite gunjan dies
yeah
listen if you don't know dies yeah if
you don't even know that name then
yo top 10 characters that could be Goku
but I remember there's this one shot uh
where it's just Darth Maul versus
Obi-Wan and I think oh [ __ ] Obi-Wan's
got the disadvantage because Darth
Maul's got a double double-ended
lightsaber how can you compare this is
one really cool shot where Obi-Wan
blocks the lightsaber with one with like
okay so Darth Maul tries to swing at him
he blocks at it like that and then he
goes he puts it behind him and blocks
him
like stab his back and I'm like that is
one of the coolest shots ever and me and
my cousin would just recreate the whole
[ __ ] Darth Maul fight in our bedroom
like oh this is this is brings back so
many memories now when you say when you
say replicate did you mean like you
don't mean like [ __ ] professional
grade like choreography right like you
just mean you just [ __ ] whacked each
other oh no we we whacked each other's
with sticks okay that's that's what I
mean yeah we whacked each other's
me and my sister as well also replicated
that fight but it was just me going
wait what and then my sister just go
ahead
because we're [ __ ] five years old I
was too busy replicating Planet of the
Apes bear in mind I've never seen planet
videos but I was replicating it yeah and
by replicating I mean like the most I
could replicate was just as I'm doing
this with a double-ended stick it was
just me going
yeah I think as a kid it was just cool
it's [ __ ] cool like do you think
because everyone's [ __ ] on the new
Trilogy now do you reckon there's gonna
be a time where the the new Trilogy
memes just kind of surface because
everyone everyone [ __ ] on the
prequels and as a kid I thought they
were everyone [ __ ] on them OG Star Wars
fans if it felt like it was just common
senseless to be like yeah the prequels
they suck yeah they've ruined episode
four to six fans said that one to three
with [ __ ] yeah yeah like I I that was
the consensus when I was like growing up
where I was like I I kind of like the
prequels but everyone around me is uh
saying their [ __ ] and so I was like
young I was like I guess I guess I just
have bad taste I guess it's [ __ ] I guess
it's [ __ ] other than that I still
thought pod racing was one of the
coolest things ever yeah that's watching
watching because I watched the original
not the original Three that second
episode wave second draw I don't know
one two three one to three I watched one
to three first all right right and I
almost feel like it made it more
interesting because I had no idea that
Luke was gonna turn but Luke yeah Luke
Anakin Anakin I had no idea that Anakin
was going to turn to a bad guy holy [ __ ]
so you actually were just like oh my God
I'm like I'm like that's [ __ ] sick
they made like the main guy into the bed
no I I feel you because I was the exact
same one like no other two movies were
doing that yeah when I was a kid so he
was like whoa no I I had I was even more
primitive in my understanding of Star
Wars because like yeah the first one I
ever watched was one yeah and then I was
like oh they have like up to three so
I'm like I'll watch three yeah and then
at the end of three I was like oh oh
there's a fourth one oh [ __ ] that must
be new and I looked at I'm like what
does it look so yeah
what happened to Yoda I did that too I
did that wait what happened to Yoda
why is it just a puppet now did they run
out of a budget why are all the Jedi's
just like [ __ ] they're not like
dancing around anymore yeah they don't
like jumping around they're just
standing still I'm like what happened
man the quality really went down after
episode three you're getting the watch
orders should start with episode one do
you think that's why it's one
that's why we call it one
why did why did George Lucas decide to
start with four
um I don't know because because when the
movie came out it was called Star Wars
episode four yeah yeah I mean he must
have actually yeah yeah yeah yeah like
when it first ever came out it didn't
become episode four after one and three
came out it started off this episode
four yeah I'm fairly recipe for disaster
now yeah he must have had some big
[ __ ] balls to be like guys this is
episode four in the second Trilogy and
then all the producers are like uh
George have you have you figured out
he's like no I'll be honest I don't know
enough about George Lucas and all of
Star Wars production to know what the
[ __ ] happened yeah I'm sure there are a
bunch of people in the comments who know
yeah I don't know one one story I've
always liked is like everyone who acted
on the original Star Wars they thought
it was [ __ ] I thought it was like [ __ ] I
thought it wasn't going to be good yeah
yeah exactly because they were like
because at the time it was so far beyond
any kind of film convention because back
back then
Star Wars did so much revolutionize the
uh sci-fi just genre in general so I I
just can't imagine what the axes were
like being like okay so we're just like
they're looking at this green screen so
and George Lucas is like okay just
pretend that we're going into hyperspace
and it just must have felt like a bunch
of [ __ ] gibberish back then could you
imagine like [ __ ] Harrison Ford just
being like so I have to act with this
[ __ ] guy in a furry costume the
entire time are you [ __ ] kid he
doesn't talk
I like it because Harrison Ford always
just acts like he doesn't give a [ __ ] no
I said I'm just like oh everyone's like
that's such a great character that's
unfortunately I just I just generally
that's just him I genuinely just didn't
give a [ __ ] he did seem pretty happy in
like Indiana Jones in that era and then
like modern Harrison Ford just you does
not want to be on oh my God he's he's
the he's he's the epitome of like jaded
I love yeah I love that because
obviously spoilers for the new Star Wars
because I I haven't seen it but I know
this happens because I mean it let's
there's only one way you're getting
Harrison Ford back and that's if you
literally killed the man which is what
he begged them I believe like there's
interviews where he's like yeah I I only
would come back if they would kill my
character really yeah yeah wow because
he wanted to be done with it oh yeah I
mean yeah understandable like and I
think he's too busy like flying planes
or something I think he crashed a plane
he's like he doesn't give a [ __ ] he
doesn't give a [ __ ] he's made his money
like do you think people will like that
in the MCU as well where it's just like
please please kill me Chris
okay okay yeah probably
yeah yeah